[Musique]
ce mois ci au sommaire de par 78
l'invité laurent mazaury à l'occasion de
l'open tv 78 kg aura lieu le 20 octobre
au golf national découverte le golf de
saint nom la bretèche avec son directeur
antoine ferrand technique et matérielle
avec le fondateur de l'ong ferb coaching
loïc ferrand et enfin le conseil du pont
[Musique]
bonjour laurent mazaury bonjour patrice
à l'arrêt ya beaucoup de façons de
pouvoir vous présenter vous êtes
directeur du développement du personnel
qui est une société spécialisée dans ce
qu'on appelle la communication
extérieure c'est tout à fait et le
digital absolument rien il ya un mot en
anglais donc plutôt from software on va
dire que michael soit militants
politiques et élus vous êtes
maire-adjoint d'elle en cause est
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous êtes président de tv 78 et on va
justement commencer par ça parce que
trop fonder tv fil 78 et cette
télévision je vois a perdu son fils sa
cause du digital dans sa vie c'est ça on
a perdu notre film n'est pas le fils en
réalité non tout simplement parce que
notre télévision historiquement été
distribués essentiellement sur le câble
est qu'aujourd'hui le câble est un
réseau que nous avons vendu on est
toujours détruite sur le câble ceux
présents sur tous les autres supports
c'est à dire sur les canaux habituels la
télévision sur les box mais également
sur digital donc le fils n'avait plus de
sens il était devenu trop réducteur et
ça veut dire aussi peut-être tv77
devient la télévision de toutes les
yvelines alors j'allais dire nous sommes
heureux mais nous sommes également
tristes puisque notre principal
confrères qui s'appelait d'une première
a cessé d'émettre
il ya quelques jours et donc
effectivement nous sommes aujourd'hui la
seule télévision disent ils mais je
dirais même la seule télévision de
l'ouest parisien patrick juste parisien
et donc avec des perspectives de
développement pour c'est pour cette
chaîne alors on va peut-être devenir un
petit peu à votre comme ça votre
parcours
je disais vous êtes militant politique
vous êtes de tendance on peut dire
centriste tout à fait tout à fait bien
sûr vous avez commencé comment quand je
suis arrivé à long cours j'ai décidé de
m'engager en politique pour faire
évoluer notre ville pour porter la
parole des citoyens que je suis que vous
n'êtes que nous sommes tous au plus près
de la réalité du terrain en s'engageant
dans ce dans un mouvement politique est
en tout cas en voulant agir sur les
choses des choses ça veut dire être élu
justement alors des cours c'est à dire
sur vraiment sur le terrain dans la
proximité tout à fait moi je m'occupe en
plus de la culture et des loisirs donc
je dirais qu'avec les sports c'est le
premier contact local avec les
associations avec les citoyens il ya
bien sûr l'urbanisme dont on a tous un
jour besoin
et puis il ya la petite enfance et les
sports et la culture sont des éléments
au contact au jour le jour avec les
concitoyens parce que le milieu
associatif est très fort puisque le
besoin de culture vous avec
l'illustration il est permanent auprès
d'un peuple
a sion et donc il faut pouvoir porter ce
message défendre ses intérêts et puis
développer au maximum la culture pour le
bénéfice du plus grand nombre
un mois quand même sur vos
responsabilités au sein de l'entreprise
pierre choquette vous êtes directeur des
développements
on se demande toujours faire des gens
faut se demander comment on concilie
justement l'engagement politique le fait
d'être élu et le fait de travailler
quand même dans une société est ce que
c'est possible c'est facile où on a une
double vie je pense que c'est possible
je n'ai pas dit que c'était facile et je
pense je ne suis pas le seul
et peut-être d'ailleurs ne sommes nous
pas assez nombreux ceux qui vont de la
société civile comme l'on dit ou d
entreprise ou d'un vrai emploi mais en
tout cas il faut ne pas compter son
temps vouloir s'engager et c'est tout à
fait conciliable effectivement vous avez
raison patrice on a souvent une double
vie c'est à dire que notre vie
professionnelle s'arrêtent vers 19h 20h
et la vie politique on comprend et le
week-end
elle est un petit peu comme un
professionnel parce qu'on essaie de
rattraper le temps qu'on a perdus la
semaine parce que malheureusement les
moyens modernes de communication nous
dépassent bien souvent et puis le
résultat environ le consacre à son
engagement politique tout en ménageant
sa vie de famille bien entendu tout ça
pour dire que ce n'est pas impossible
c'est à la portée à mon avis de tous
pour peu qu'on veuille s'en donner les
moyens
oui c'est un faut vraiment le vouloir il
faut le vouloir assez d'accord alors c
est ce qu il reste un petit peu de place
justement pour le golf
non c'est mon troisième problème il m'en
reste passé vous avez vous avez raison
mais au moins on arrive à le concilier
certes les hommes politiques ou des gens
qui travaillent beaucoup sont rarement
de grands golfeurs ou alors il faut
avoir une profession qui vous libère
beaucoup de temps pour pouvoir
progresser
salehi par trump n'a jamais autant joué
que deux filets présidence des états
unis dans cette île à bonn un peu vous
avez un peu je ne suis pas encore un peu
de temps alors on va on va parler de cet
open tv 78 qui a lieu le 20 octobre tout
à fait ici même au golf national sur le
golf national
c'est un scramble à l'offre expliqué
peut-être pour les gens qui savent pas
ce qu'est ce qu'on veut on joue à
plusieurs là ça sera deux la meilleure
balle à chaque fois c'est sur de bons
sondages a toujours l'impression de bien
jouer en général ont des cartes qui sont
bonnes
c'est un petit peu comme la ryder cup
c'est un des rares façon joseph en
équipe et ça rajoute tout l'intérêt
par rapport à un sport individuel qui
effectivement parfois être un peu
difficile mais moralement ça rajoute de
l'intérêt ça rajoute des challenges au
jeu ça permet de tenter des coups qu'on
ne tenterait pas d'habitude
et cette année se confrontaient des
parcours parfois qu'on n'oserait pas
jouer parce qu'il nous semble peut-être
insurmontable quand on a un niveau de
jeu peut-être moyens et c'est très
convivial et c'est très très convivial
c'est un grand moment de convivialité
j'allais dire c'est pas péjoratif quand
ils retrouvent leurs actions comme on
l'a un peu quand on joue aux boules
oui c'est un peu ça aussi après tout
lorsqu'on veut justement depuis que vous
êtes arrivé à la présidence de tv 78
vous avez donné une place importante au
golf
oui oui c'est dur aussi on veut lancer
pourtant alors c'est aussi une volonté
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et dès que nous sommes aussi la
télévision bien sûr de l'agglomération
saint quentin en yvelines parce que nous
recevons la ryder cup en 2018 quelle
sera ici même au taureau dans ce lieu
magique parce que nous le savons depuis
quelques jours nous sommes capitale
olympique en 2004 et que le golf c'est
une olympiade revenus un sport olympique
il aura lieu aussi ici et donc il faut
ancrer le territoire et les habitudes
des gens pour apprécier le golf jouer au
golf le considérer comme étant
démocratique et comme étant un sport
accessible ce que pendant des années
malheureusement il n'a pas été ce n'est
pas l'image qu'ils avaient et donc il
était important pour nous dans les
yvelines
qui plus est qui les départements de
france nous avons le plus de golf ils
réclament savoir c'est un pays golfique
par excellence et donc il fallait que
nous inscrivions la télévision locale
dans ce mouvement golfique pour qu'un
maximum de gens puissent y adhérer
trouvez ce sport passionnant vouloir y
jouer parce que c'est vraiment évident
pour nous et puis montrer que c'est
accessible c'est un sport accessible et
comme je l'aï dit tout à leur patrie
c'est un sport qui est à la fois
individuel mais qui est également
peut-être un sport d'équipé
c'est une très belle expérience de vie
alors cette année c'est le premier repas
donc il aura lieu sur une journée le 20
octobre mais le projet c'est de la voie
sur deux jours à partir de là notre
prochain à partir de 2018 c'est cela
alors c'est un événement que nous
voulons avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines inscrire dans la
récurrence s'inscrire dans un programme
annuel est donc l'an prochain
vous avez tout à fait raison il se
déroulera sur deux jours nous comptons
réservé une journée entière aux
entreprises parce que nous avons sur ce
territoire est énormément d'entreprises
puisque c'est le deuxième pôle
francilien après la défense
beaucoup de gens des entreprises
collaborateurs joue au golf et donc sont
demandeurs d'avoir une telle compétition
et puis bien entendu le 2
jour qui va sera l'open ouvert à tous
ben justement ce que je vous propose est
parce qu on le fait avec tous les
invités de cette émission là alors
malheureusement je vous prends entre
deux rendez vous de votre boulot donc
vous n'êtes pas équipés est ce que vous
voulez bien que taper quelques balles et
puis au soumettra votre swing à un pro
qui s'appelle sébastien qui regarde un
peu ce qu'il faut changer ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir du travail surtout dans
cette tenue
patrice ok on fait ça avec plaisir merci
beaucoup l'auront nos amis merci patrice
ce
bonjour à tous bienvenue au groupe
national on m'a confié une nouvelle fois
la tâche de naizin swing ce coup ci
c'est celui de monsieur l'euro mazaury
on voit qu'il a un swing qui est très
très rapide
une tendance à utiliser principalement
les bras les mains voilà dans un swing
qui est un petit peu un petit peu
violent en tout cas à mon goût on voit
qu'au retour il ya une tendance à couper
légèrement la balle est ce que je
préconiserais est plutôt dans un premier
temps de redresser légèrement sa posture
puisqu'il a un tout petit peu trop
inclinée ce qui rend la rotation un
petit peu délicate à à effectuer en fait
et ensuite dans la descente on
s'aperçoit qu'il a le bac swing est pas
si mal finalement une belle rotation la
phase deux clubs étaient assez square
club est assez bien placé on va dire et
à partir de là une tendance à force
énormément avec les bras la descente et
il serait judicieux qu'il essaye de
travailler déjà un petit peu plus avec
l'action du bas du corps
une action un peu plus marquée des
hanches qui viennent s'ouvrir puis des
épaules et ensuite des bras qui viennent
prendre le relais derrière pour qu'il
puisse arriver enfin tout simplement
avoir un swing un peu plus efficient
voilà il m'a donné plus de vitesse plus
d'énergie et plus droit tout simplement
en dépensant moins d'énergie en ayant à
soigner un peu moins violente ce qui lui
permettra à l'arrivée avoir plus de
régularité
[Musique]
si je vous dis trophée lancôme vous
allez me dire immédiatement saint nom la
bretèche lui le golf de saint nom la
bretèche grâce à ce trophée
il y avait les plus grands golfeurs se
disputer le titre sur ce parcours est
connue de tous les français peut-être
même connu dans le monde entier
saint nom la bretèche on en parle avec
son directeur anton différents bonjour à
toi de faire un bon jour vous êtes le
directeur du golf de saint nom la
bretèche
depuis 2004 on verra après parce que
vous avez une histoire plus longue avec
avec ce golf mais c'est vrai que quand
on dit ça nom la bretèche pour ce par
tous même les gens qui joue pas au golf
se dit c'est vrai que c'est un des rares
golf reconnu partout quoi ah oui c'est
vrai qu'on a eu cette chance d'avoir un
tournoi remportant le trophée lancôme
c'était vraiment le tournoi de référence
tournoi qui avait été créée en soixante
dix par gaëtan bong d'algues qui a duré
quand même jusqu'à en 2003 et se
tournant on le voit encore aujourd'hui
c'est une référence
les gens viennent aux commissions
d'admission ils disent je me souviens
quand je venais voir le lot comme donc
c'est quelque chose qui resté dans les
mémoires et qui nous porte énormément de
notoriété du club
faut dire que ont participé ont gagné
d'ailleurs selon comme banana plupart
des grands joie et une palmeraie
ballesteros il ya nous sommes enfin tous
les tous les grands de grands grands de
chaque année oui il y avait il va dire
sorte d'amour de ballesteros pour ce
parcours l'église du village n'aurait
d'yeux deux ou trois fois oui bien sûr
mais il avait surtout il était tellement
spectaculaire dans son jeu on voit les
images de malte 0 ça genou qui regardait
encore sa balle notamment autre numéro
et c'est vrai qu'il avait un jeu il
s'éparpille est tellement ils donnent
rendez vous sur le green libye revenait
à chaque fois c'était absolument
formidable
disait vous avez une histoire plus
longue avec ce golf à ce que le
gouvenement 59 cousin fait un point tous
les métiers du groupe salins là vous
êtes directeur aujourd'hui vous avez été
aussi j'ai été alerté de renseigner
d'adolf j'ai été pro de golf
effectivement j'ai passé pro en 83 j'ai
été aux états unis pendant trois à
baccarat tonnes et je suis revenu
ensuite et et je suis devenu directeur
du golfe en 1990 alors c'est un an
d'abord en amont est dans les bâtiments
c'est une c'est une ancienne bergerie
alors quand c'est une ferme ferme des
baux qui était un peu dans la continuité
de versailles puisque c'est une ferme du
xviiie et qui a été entièrement rénové
par monsieur feo donc en 1959 avec
l'idée de construire un golf exactement
c'était c'était le premier golf
immobilier puisque en fin de compte ce
golf est conçu avec des maisons autour
raison il ya 150 maisons
c'est un peu dans le concept de ces
golfs comme l'ont été
bondues d'ailleurs golf immobilières et
en fin de compte c'était il y avait le
golfe et ses maisons le domaine de la
tuilerie c'était vraiment les grands
développements de l'ouest parisien
c'était poquelin alors il ya une très
bonne équipe de dolphin il ya eu
beaucoup de résultats comme tous les à
part des grands clubs de foot qui arrive
à tenir leur l'auront sinon c'est vrai
que d'avoir des filles en ce moment on
espère voir sa part une promotion à
terre donc c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué en tout cas ça reste un
objectif permanent à saint nom d' avoir
naturellement des équipes présentes dans
chaque catégorie et encore une fois en
essayant de promouvoir les enfants de
membres qui sont notre priorité
alors c'est un golf de membres
essentiellement c'est à dire que il y a
il ya des moyens une action 1
statutairement statutairement donc le
golfe ami l'actionnaire donc on reste
vraiment sur cette disposition
statutaire et aujourd'hui on a ce qu'on
appelle un turnover à peu près de 50 man
2 par an ce qui permet d'accueillir des
nouveaux membres annuellement qui sont
principalement des membres par
cooptation c'est à dire des membres qui
trouvent des amis qui les recommande au
club et qu'on fait rentrer tous les ans
vous avez deux parcours le bleu et le
rouge
et vous avez en plus un petit parcours
d'initiation sur le parcours blanc donc
vraiment tout
tout les éléments pour pouvoir
s'entraîner c'est vrai que il ya très
rarement de la tonte principalement en
semaine et vous voyez aujourd'hui on
tourne à peu près avec 120 140 personnes
jours oui le week-end 200-250 qui permet
au parcours d'adoption b très facilement
que facilement quelle est la différence
entre les deux la différence principale
à l'est pas tellement technique c'est
que le bleu le neuf ne revient pas au
club house donc quand vous allez sur les
bleus ses principes ses membres du son
ou alors que le neuf lui à cet agrément
de revenir au club du rouge le rouge
pardon mais mais le trophée lancôme a
permis aux deux parcours d'être au même
niveau puisque l'on mixé a remixé par
composite et la montage de ce parcours
composite c'est qu'il a donné la même
exigence qualitative de parcours alors
c'est un parcours hockey qui est assez
difficile franck uc et qui est de niveau
b dans lequel on voit bien d'ailleurs de
départ d un peu quand même un peu quand
même on n'est pas obligé d'être de
droite ou droit est très long pour ces
lieux toujours mais la difficulté c'est
de faire cohabiter si vous voulez à la
fois ce golf sportif le golf loisy
absolument et aujourd'hui c'est un des
enjeux die hard et avoir dormi aussi que
les manques qui arrive le week-end qui
ont une semaine où ils ont envie de se
détendre le week-end qu'ils arrivent pas
et que cette angoisse du trou numéro un
on vous avait dit hors limites ou une
balle perdue
donc c'est vrai que mon essaye à la fois
de conserver la difficulté du parcours
pour les joueurs de 1re série mais
ladite l'avancement qu'on peut faire sur
nos marques de départ et la nature dont
on traite nos reufs permet justement
joueurs goualch loisir de profiter avec
un peu moins de stress le week-end alors
si vous avez vos membres évidemment il
ya le lard et des requêtes qui arrivent
en vélo stationnaire dans les yvelines
en 2018 durant les jeux olympiques en
2004 pour vous quel est l'intérêt de ces
épreuves c'est que ça amène de nouveaux
golfeurs ya pas un golf aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient pas sensible
à son recrutement
même s'il se fait par les membres mais
aujourd'hui les faits ryder cup on
l'attend depuis longtemps et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est bien partis dans
cette dynamique et les jeux olympiques
ont encore confirmé si vous laisser
durer donc aujourd'hui nous attendons
énormément de la ryder cup la fédération
on a cette sensibilité sur le
développement des nouveaux golfeurs qui
après devrait revenir dans nos clubs
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut voilà vous
souhaiter pour les années qui viennent
est ce qu est ce que vous vous souhaiter
pour le golf de saint nom ce que
j'espère c'est qu'il aura d'aussi belles
années dans l'avenir qu'il a eue d'année
pour le passé ouais et pour ça il est
important effectivement que des nouveaux
membres ronde pour le faire venir et
assurer sa succession qu'il y est
naturellement des résultats sportifs et
que l'on continue avec le comité qui est
très attaché à sa a développé le confort
pour les membres pour que notre club
conserve son d'autres activités alors je
reviens d'un mot sur le trophée lancôme
est ce que vous espérez que voilà dans
l'avenir une grande compétition comme
celle là puisse puisse remettre et parce
que après tout c'est un ours est connu
dans le monde entier grâce à graçia da
ce trophée lancôme
écoutez si je devais vous répondre en
anglais je vous dirais alias dribbles
oui c'est que forcément ce qu'on a vécu
et des souvenirs que nous avons du long
comme ça et souvenirs exceptionnels pour
se rend compte que ça fait progresser
les parcours ça fait progresser nos
structures sa motiver le personnel ça a
intéressé les membres ça a facilité la
promotion et de recrutement des membres
donc aujourd'hui
forcément on rêve d'un tournoi d'un
tournoi qui correspondrait naturellement
aux exigences du club
mais nos structures sont prêtes parce
que le lancôme a construit au fil des
années sur ces structures d'accueil la
proximité son emplacement
si demain il y avait un partenaire de
qualité avec l'accord du comité bien sûr
on rêverait d'avoir un événement majeur
comme on l'a vu par le passé c'est tous
merci beaucoup c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
on va parler un peu de coaching avec lou
différend avec le créateur de londres
héroïque ce coaching qui est un
enseignant on va vous parler un petit
peu technique on va même voir un petit
cours avec rex thierry qui est là donc
tout ce qu'il faut savoir notamment sur
les approches on va le savoir grâce à
des lectures
le hic ferrand bonjour pourtant patrice
alors on est à sivry la flore et c'est
là que vous avez installé votre académie
l'ancré en coaching coaching pourquoi
kutch coach prof c'est pareil c'est un
peu différent alors moi ce que je
voulais vraiment cessé d'être beaucoup
plus proche de l'élève
c'est ça mon aspects coaching alors
enseignant simplement on voit les allait
se passer on tape des balles et pire on
les oublie un petit peu là le coaching
on va les suivre
d'accord c'est très personnel et très
personnalisable att est alors vous avez
installé votre académie ici et ça
consiste en quoi cette académie alors
l'académie c'est retravaillé tous les
panels du jeu du golfe mais je me suis
spécialisé dans le petit jeu c'est à
dire tous les coups à moins de 100
mètres si je peut généraliser un petit
peu donc dans mon jargon c'est ce qu'on
appelait le wedding et le putting
vous êtes de formation vous êtes un pro
de golf vous avez fait plusieurs choses
à vos effets de la gestion je fais la
gestion sportive
donc pour être directoire de golf à la
base et je me suis dit que travailler
sur des hectares à l'extérieur au soleil
c'était pas plus mal donc maintenant
fait plutôt le lancer du mois plus tôt
que la gestion proprement dit est ce que
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
dans l'enseignement depuis que vous avez
appris à jouer
voilà c'est très différent avant on
apprenait beaucoup plus au practice
oui on répétait le mouvement on
travaillait vraiment à part faire un
petit peu le swing sa son image alors
que maintenant on va amener les gens
beaucoup plus sur le parcours on va
travailler beaucoup plus en situation
moi j'ai tapé des heures au practice le
règne de voir devant un parcours exact
exactement et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
c'est plus alors c'est plus vidic et
vidéo pour les uns
beaucoup joué un parcours plus et c'est
plus rennes aussi parce qu'on n'a pas on
n'a pas les mêmes sensations fortes
pressions pour rien alors il ya cette
idée là il ya cette idée là qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment de notions de cible c'est
très difficile de vraiment s'imaginer un
green un fairway inquiets le chemin sur
lequel on évolue
c'est au practice est assez abstrait
alors que la en situation pas forcément
c'est beaucoup plus facile
alors est ce qu'il ya des méthodes
d'orsay du monde dont vous vous réclamez
il ya des écoles comme celle du jeune
buteur comme ça tout à fait ce qui est
ce qu'elle est que des vols courts et
crépus où est-ce que vous avez essayé de
concevoir un annoncé mots qui soit le
vôtre proprement alors il ya toujours
une personnalisation du pro par contre
moi j'ai vraiment voulu être au plus
près de l'élève
c'était forcément je m'adaptais d'accord
en fonction de la mobilité de son corps
en fonction de sa visualisation fonction
de ça de la gd exactement voilà on fait
du total sur mesure il vous accompagne
et alors on peut on peut dire voilà moi
j'ai envie d'aller faire tel parcours
vous accompagner bien sûr pour les
parcours accompagné c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle on peut se déplacer partout en
france on peut on peut aussi partir à
l'étranger il n'y a pas de ya pas de
limite
alors le qu'il fallait comme le golf est
il arrivé dans votre vie
moi je tombais dans le goal tout à fait
par hasard puisque je fais partie en
ronald et un pour cent des jeunes qui
ont connu le golf à l'école oui c'est
rare en plus justement commencé le golf
c'est conseillé ou est-ce qu'il faut
attendre trouve un peu de maturité un
peu de talent qui n'ont pas forcément
c'est vrai que c'est plus compliqué
derrière pour intéresser
un enfant mais moi j'ai commencé le baby
golf à partir de 3 ans ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'un jeune en dessous
de 8 ans il a encore entre guillemets
son cerveau reptilien basique on va il
va travailler dans le mime il va pas
réfléchir donc c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour lui à quelque chose et donc
ça ça reste après ça reste oui il ya les
personnes les mois qui viennent me voir
je leur demande quel sport ils ont fait
pour avoir un petit peu leur façon de
fonctionner il me disait j'ai fait ça
mais quand j'étais tout petit
aujourd'hui justement tout ce que vous
avez fait avant 8 ans est très
intéressant parce qu'on va faire
maintenant si on veut vous trouvez il ya
un site
oui tout à fait donc langue fleurie
coaching points comme point commun c'est
très simple bon sens du coaching pub
loïck peyron type
[Musique]
alors va ouvrir d'autres séquences
technique on va parler de footing avec
loïck peyron lui graffiti c'est quoi
c'est le fait d'adapter le matériel ou
aux joueurs voilà maintenant on fait du
sur mesure il ya des clubs comme un
simple mais on peut les modifier en
fonction de là c'est les mecs vous avez
un club comme ça qui est un peu
particulier parce que il ya quoi
décision
ça s'est passé non c'est un capteur qui
va nous permettre justement de voir de
modéliser le swing du joueur en 3d et de
regarder parce qu'il conviendrait en
fonction de sa morphologie et de son
système de jeu eh ben je vais vous
laisser faire cette démonstration de
fatigue avec à nous qui est un très
grand joueur
peut-être avec des très grands déjà tout
à fait alors on est là pour plusieurs
choses ont déjà arrivé à déterminer le
club qui te correspond on va regarder un
petit peu ce que ça donne au niveau du
swing donc ça c'est ton string donc tu
as déjà dans un premier temps au niveau
de son installation la ligne en
pointillés elle est en train de marquer
le fait que tu donnes donc le fait
d'avoir les mains très en avant sur ton
installation un côté gauche qui a ses
forces
alors si je peux être matérialisé un
petit peu ce que tu fais je vais te
représenter un petit peu ce qu'on voit
simplement à la caméra on a une montée
de clubs qui se fait assez rapidement de
l'intérieur lorsque j'entends intérieur
c'est tout ce qui est derrière toi est
ce que j'entends en extérieur c'est tout
ce qui est face à toi intérieur c'est un
club qui va monter très rapidement ici
donc derrière on pourrait s'attendre en
haut de la montée avoir un club plus
revient par dessus simplement pour
compenser alors toi ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tu engages quand
même le corps est mécaniquement la
rotation de ce corps va permettre au
club de revenir de l'intérieur ça c'est
une bonne chose
on arrive on est assez bien jusqu'à
cette image là et là sur la zone
d'impact est un tout petit peu après on
a des mains qui se libèrent et donc on a
un club qui repart alex à l'intérieur
donc il repart derrière plutôt que finir
sa course
techniquement ce que te permettra les
bonnes caractéristiques haut niveau du
club savoir accord qui ne se bloque pas
est un club donc il continue sa course
et qui se relâchent beaucoup plus vers
la cible donc là par rapport à ce qu'on
me montre sur le ring il te faudra un
club avec un rebond assez faible
d'accord contre un rebond assez faible
ça permettra justement à ton club de
rester moins longtemps en interaction
avec le sol et donc de transmettre plus
d'énergie à la balle donc par rapport à
ça sur les pings g15 ton pitch est à 45
degrés donc si on prend l'ouverture la
plus ouverte dans ton sac donc 50 il
voudrait il nous faudrait donc un club
de 50 degrés donc ce que je te propose
maintenant ce qu'on va essayer justement
des clubs à 50 degrés voire un petit peu
les autres caractéristiques on pourrait
mettre en place ok c'est pas
[Musique]
bon laissons le 18 de l'albatros comme
tu me l'a demandé j'ai joué offensif
mon coup de bois 3 j'ai fait enroulée
josé je suis à gauche du green
et bien voilà j'ai un look je crois
ouais ouais ben lobb par là bas si
facile quand même attendu justine je
croyais que le lobe c'était le coup le
plus difficile du golfe n'ont pas
forcément on va chercher ton sans
nouvelle je prends l'un qu'elle prend le
112 le plus ouvert donc le 58 degrés
allez c'est parti
alors là tu vois patrice sur un sur un
lob comme sa hotte a quand même un bon
lie à ses aplats et bien il faut pas
trop se prendre la tête
il faut tout simplement utiliser
l'ouverture de la phase deux clubs pour
faire monter la base donc il n'y a pas
besoin d'actionner les mains donc tu
ouvres un petit peu la face deux clubs à
l'impact et tu fais un comme un grand
type normal sans actionner les mains
voila et tu tournes tu t'en autour de
toi et tu fais bien attention d'avoir
sur les mains en face du sternum
un joueur juste m
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]